So I've been informed about a couple of
things this week that have really been
bothering me and I thought that I wasn't
sure what to do about it.
I've been communicating with some of my
friends and colleagues about it,
but that wasn't enough,
so I thought I'd try to write my
thoughts down and then talk about them a
little bit and see where I got with
that.
So I've entitled this talk Professor
Against Political correctness.
And the reason for that is because it's
blunt and to the point,
um,
I'm very concerned about what's
happening in the universities.
It's not so bad in Canada.
I've been fortunate,
very fortunate the University of
Toronto,
but they're continually things
happening,
including in the administration here and
in the broader political world.
That makes me very nervous.
I like to attribute that to the fact
that I know something about the way that
totalitarian authoritarian political
states develop and I can't help but
think that I'm seeing a fair bit of that
right now.
So I guess I also wanted to do this
because there is a misapprehension that
everyone in academia is politically
correct.
And that's his true very frequently
among social scientists,
about 20 percent of whom identify
themselves as Marxists,
which in my estimation,
by the way,
is no better than identifying as Nazis
given the murderousness of the Marxist
doctrine and the fact that we know how
it's turned out when implemented in
multiple countries now.
Um,
but I'm not politically correct.
And,
uh,
I want to talk to you today about why
all this worries me.
So I got wind of two events this week.
Um,
one actually dates from last May.
there is a legislation passed or the
first reading of legislation in the
Federal House set in Canada about a bill
called [inaudible],
which was an,
is an attempt to alter the Canadian bill
of human rights.
It's tangled up with another
organization that operates at a
provincial level in Canada,
in Ontario,
which is the province I reside in called
the Ontario Human Rights Commission.
And uh,
as far as I can tell what happens at the
Ontario Human Rights Commission is
rapidly turned into policy in multiple
provinces across Canada.
And perhaps increasingly at the federal
level,
there's a liberal government in power
that's the name of the political party
in Ontario and now there's liberal
government federally.
And um,
there's obviously a fair bit of cross
influence for better,
for worse.
Also this week I got wind of a
University of Toronto Human Resources
Initiative that also upset me,
I guess we could say quite profoundly.
And so I thought I'd talk about all of
those and try to see if I could make
some sense out of them.
So I've,
I'm making this video because I don't
really know what else to do.
I've talked to some colleagues and I've
talked to some colleagues as I or some,
some,
some people inside the university and
outside the university that I know and
they're upset and worried about this,
but unclear about what to do.
And all of this scares me I guess.
And here's why the law,
the changes to the law scare me because
cause they,
they put into
the legal substructure of the culture.
Certain assumptions about basic human
nature that not only do I believe to be
untrue,
I think there are also dangerous.
And ideologically motivated.
I also don't think that the reason for
the legal changes is the stated reason.
The Lord scare me.
The doctrines behind the law scare me.
You know,
when there,
when there's a law,
there's a body of thought that's
associated with a body of
interpretations that are associated with
it,
that flesh out the law.
Because the law is a pretty bare thing.
And I've read,
I wouldn't say extensively because
extensively is a lot,
but I've read enough about the doctrines
behind the laws so that,
that has also may also makes me very
nervous.
Increasingly,
I see that these more radical ideas,
the ideas that we're going to discuss
are bought in people buy in at the
administrative level in large
organizations,
corporate,
governmental.
It doesn't matter,
it,
it as long as the organization is large,
there's increasing administrative buy
in.
A lot of this seems to me to be driven
by human resources departments.
Um,
which I think are generally the most
pathological elements of large
organizations.
And I say that because I've actually had
fairly extensive experience dealing with
human resources departments.
Um,
I think her training is very politically
correct.
Like many disciplines,
we'll talk about that later.
Um,
the people behind the doctrines also
scare me.
I think that generally they're a very
bad combination of resentful,
uninformed,
and,
um,
that's good enough.
Resentful and uninformed.
That's good enough.
Uh,
I also think that their aims are
destructive rather than constructive.
They claim constructive aims,
but of course everyone claims
constructive aims.
But the actions that I see undertaken
seemed to be to be driven by resentment
and primarily by resentment.
And,
and so I did,
I doubt the validity of the claims.
The claims are always for equality and
diversity and that kind of thing.
And those words are very easy to say,
but a lot harder to put into practice.
So I'm scared by the people behind the
doctrines.
I'm scared by the response of my
colleagues at the university.
A number of them are unnerved by the
continual move towards political
correctness.
And I'm gonna tell you a couple of
responses that I've got recently from
people that I think are quite brave by
the way,
um,
but worried about making a statement,
putting their careers on their line,
worried about being tortured to death by
people online,
worried about administrative over
response or even administrative response
worried,
well,
here's why.
The things that I'm seeing at work will
have to be discussed in a phone
conversation.
This is a professor in American
professor.
I asked how this person was feeling
about
the position that they held at the
university.
I'm the person said the thing that I'm
seeing at work will have to be discussed
in a phone conversation.
It's hard for me personally to explain
it in an email.
I'm not certain this is the career path
I'm interested in anymore.
I actually find myself sensory things,
censoring things that I'd normally say
to students and I'm not sure how to stop
that.
Self Censorship Censorship leads to me
not truly educating them in a manner
that will let me feel like I've done my
job well.
It's not as much from the administration
yet as it is from the students.
See,
I don't see that so much at the
University of Toronto.
The students here are so terrified of
the job market and generally speaking,
so diligent,
conscientious that they are not
particularly sidetracked by political
correctness.
So,
but that's obviously not my colleague's
experience in,
in the US.
This is in California,
another colleague,
this is more local,
said something I thought was very
intelligent.
I think that's why this sort of thing is
so difficult to stand up to,
uh,
the personal consequences of objecting
are and this person is referring to the
possibility of adverse job effects,
I guess effects on employment and you
think tenure would protect people
against that and I suppose it probably
does,
but that doesn't mean that people aren't
necessarily willing to put it to the
test.
Um,
and they're worried about being
pilloried online by social justice
warriors and,
and,
and so on,
and having the reputation savaged and
demolished.
So you know,
and that,
that's a good,
that's a reasonable fear.
Especially given the next part,
which is the effect of my objection on
society will be minuscule.
So there's this combination.
That's the idea anyways,
the personal consequences of jet of
objecting or potentially huge and the
social effects are minuscule.
There'll be no positive effect.
And so the thinking goes,
why put yourself and potentially your
family and your financial stability and
all of that at risk by speaking out when
the consequences will be will be
minimal.
And you know,
I've talked to other people outside of
academia,
academia writers for example,
we've had friends who've made a comment
online,
you know,
which they thought was rather innocuous.
That's quoted over and over again in
some,
sometimes in major newspapers as
emblematic of their particular stance
and that shows them in a very harsh
light.
So anyways,
this particular colleague concluded by
saying we should have acted 10 years
ago.
Well,
you know,
I feel for both of these colleagues,
I think they're both excellent educators
by the way.
And they're also,
I would say,
classically liberal people,
you know,
um,
they're not,
they're not you,
you wouldn't call them conservatives,
you,
you certainly wouldn't call them right
wingers.
Their people,
their concerns aren't driven by their
political ideologies.
It's as simple as that.
Um,
their concerns are driven by their,
by their continued continual
observations,
increasingly continual observations that
things are not going in the proper
direction and universities and that it's
becoming increasingly difficult for
professors and,
and,
and students for that matter,
at least have of a particular kind of
political orientation to even have the
opportunity to say what they think.
So,
okay.
So that scares me.
It scares me when I see decent people
and I think people who are more
courageous than average,
I'm frightened into submission and
considering altering their career paths
because they don't feel that they can
say what they think anymore and they're
afraid of the direction that the
universities are going.
So yeah,
that's scary.
So then I'm,
I'm a clinical psychologist.
This is starting to affect my clients.
I've had three clients in the last two
years who have been and who have been
driven near the point of insanity.
I'm by politically correct occurrences
at work.
One of them was a bank employee.
What what finally did her in
fundamentally was
she sent me a very long email chain
referring to a series of discussions
that happened in this bank internally
about whether or not the word flip
chart,
you know,
referring to those large pads of paper
that you put up on a stand.
You can flip forward and drawn kind of
an archaic technology.
Now whether or not the word flip chart
was pejorative and racist and the reason
for that was that apparently the word
flip can be used pejoratively to refer
to Filipinos,
which was something I didn't even know
and I suppose a Filipino could
conceivably take offense to having a pad
of paper named flip chart.
Although it's hard to imagine the
circumstances under which that might
arise or at least once.
It was hard to imagine that.
Anyways,
she gave me access to a string of email
conversations about that particular
topic and the bank did eventually agree
to stop using the term flip chart.
I don't know what they replaced it with,
um,
but you know,
she was a very,
very sensible person,
an immigrant by the way,
who couldn't reconcile
her requirement,
you know,
her moral requirement to work hard and
be productive and be sensible and be
conscientious with the fact that people
were being called,
called on to alter their behavior in
ways that were absolutely nonsensical.
And she was from an eastern European
country.
And of course for her,
this was reminiscent of the tactics of
the worst of the ideologues in the
19 seventies and eighties and before
that.
So it was very,
very hard on her.
She,
she,
she was very,
very stressed by the situation at work.
And then I had another client who worked
in an HR department in a major
educational institute and he was always
being called on to manifest to support
for various feminist initiatives at the
educational institute.
And he wasn't really all that
comfortable presenting himself as a pro
feminist because he actually wasn't one
and you can argue one way or another
about the propriety of that.
And that's really not my point.
My point is,
is that he believed and I think with
cars that his job would have been in
jeopardy if he would have let his
objections to the demands of the
political environment within the
workplace,
if he would have made those objections
known and it.
And I would say he,
he's,
he's a little bit more,
here's a little bit more to the right
than most of the people that,
that I've talked with,
but not to any great degree.
Although like many people,
I think he's being driven in that
direction by the continual radical moves
to the left that seemed to be part and
parcel of every organization in,
uh,
in,
in maybe in modern Western society now.
And then the other client that I had who
was very much troubled by this was a
social worker who was,
was,
I think she was,
she was,
she was an immigrant as well,
quite conservative from.
She was from a conservative culture and
was very much,
um,
it had very much difficulty with the
demands,
for example,
that she allow a non surgically altered
transsexual men free access to the
women's shelters and the women's
shelters,
for example,
here are some of the people in them
obviously say,
or Muslim women who come from very
conservative cultures who really can't
even function in a situation where,
you know,
a,
a male,
a biological male has been given access
to what in principle is supposed to be a
woman's shelter.
And that was one of many things that,
that bothered her,
but we don't need to get into that.
The point is,
is that I've had people who've been
driven to seek psychological counseling
because of the effect of politically
correct oppression on them in the
workplace.
And so that's worrisome.
Um,
so that's a whole bunch of things that
make me nervous.
And then my own response scares me.
I find this stuff maddening.
Um,
I can't really believe the amount of
foolishness that,
that,
that has accumulated around these rather
contentious Marxist semi Marxist
political issues.
Uh,
which I have,
which I don't,
I have no respect for,
uh,
as I said already,
I think that Marxism and neo Marxism is
no better than fascism and neo fascism.
Uh,
I think the historical evidence for that
is absolutely clear.
I can't understand why we think it's
acceptable for academics and their
followers to call themselves Marxists to
neo Marxists,
but we,
we,
we would,
we would not for a second countenance
the same thing from the fascists and the
neo fascists.
Anyways,
the opposite side of it is that I'm
nervous about doing this lecture and
I've also become nervous about some of
the things that I'm teaching,
which I think I'm going to discuss this
a little bit further,
a little further on in this,
in this discussion.
I think that some of the things that I
say in my lectures now might be illegal.
I think they might even be,
I,
that they might even be sufficient to me
to be for me to be brought before the
Ontario Human Rights Commission under
their amended hate speech laws.
And that scares me as well.
And it scares me that I think that
because it sounds paranoid,
but I'm
most of the time in the past when I've
been concerned that the,
that something is going to happen at an
administrative or bureaucratic level at
the university,
that it,
it's,
it's frequently the case that when I'm
worried about something happening that
it does actually happen and that it's
not so much worry as an ability to see
high probability outcomes down into the
future.
So,
and you know,
even if even if the things that I'm
saying are haven't been made illegal or
heaven forbid transformed into suddenly
into hate speech,
I am nervous that they might be.
And even that's making it more difficult
for me to teach because in order for me
to teach,
I have to say what I think is true.
And I can't do that if I'm afraid.
If I have to be afraid of the
consequences.
All,
all,
all stopped talking.
You know,
even all,
if you can say one thing or the other
and there's a lot of pressure not to say
the first thing.
And you could just as easily say the
second thing.
It's just as easy to say the second
thing,
why not just not bothered with it,
you know?
Well,
the reason I can do that is because if I
have something to say and I don't say
it,
then it drives me crazy and so on.
That's not something I'm willing to.
I'm not willing to go down that path and
I've already decided that I'm going to
try to tell people what I think and,
and to tell them what I think to be the
truth,
even though it's the truth that I think
that I'm not saying that what I think is
true.
I mean,
who knows what's true.
That's why we have freedom of speech
rate to sort out what's true so.
But I can tell you that it's true that
I'm scared about this and I think that's
appalling.
I really think that's appalling.
All right,
so this is bill.
See 16 in and somebody sent this to me
this week and pointing out what was
happening with regards to this
fundamental Canadian human rights
legislation.
And I'm going to do a bad job of this
because it takes,
it takes more time than I have to do
this properly.
So all I can do is tell you my initial
thoughts and try to justify them as best
I can.
It would take months to do this lecture
properly and I haven't gotten months to
do it properly,
so I'm going to have to do it badly.
So here we go.
So Bill [inaudible] is an act to amend
the Canadian Human Rights Act and the
criminal code.
So these are major.
This is a major amendment because the
human rights act and the criminal code
or major pieces of legislation,
they affect everyone.
And the consequences for contravening
them are severe as severe as severe
consequences can be short of you know,
of illness and death.
So there are nontrivial pieces of
legislation.
Now,
if you guys aren't in Canada,
you might wonder why you should care
about this.
But what's happening in Canada is
happening throughout the West.
So I'm going to concentrate on the local
occurrences,
but you can think,
you can be sure they're emblematic of
similar things happening in your
jurisdictions.
So because this is certainly not only a
Canadian problem and in fact I would say
to some fairly large degree,
Canada has been reasonably free of this,
especially at the university level and
it's almost as if we're importing it
unnecessarily.
But okay.
This enactment amends the Canadian Human
Rights Act to add gender identity and
gender expression to the list of
prohibited grounds of discrimination.
Now,
this amendment has only gone through
first reading.
This was back in May,
but similar legislation has already been
passed in a number of provinces.
Those are the smaller like this,
they're like states.
They're the smaller subdivisions of the
Canadian political system.
So this hasn't been made into law
federally,
but it,
it,
it's,
it's likely going to.
And it already has at the provincial
level as I said.
So
this enactment also amends the criminal
code to extend the protection against
hate propaganda set out in that act to
any section of the public that is
distinguished by gender identity or
expression.
And to clearly set out that evidence
that have no fence was motivated by
bias,
prejudice,
or hate based on gender identity or
expression constitutes an aggravating
circumstance that a court must take into
consideration when it imposes a
sentence.
Okay,
so that's basically a hate crime,
a modification.
So if you commit a crime,
well that's one thing,
but if you commit a crime and it's
motivated by bias,
prejudice,
or hate based on age,
sex,
race,
ethnic identity,
and so,
so and other things,
including now gender identity or
expression,
then that makes the crime worse.
It falls into the category of hate
crime.
And so that's what this modification is
intended to produce or to bring about.
So any,
any crime that is associated with bias,
prejudice,
or hate based on gender identity or
expression is now an aggravating
circumstance.
Okay,
so,
so it's a hate crime.
Now I have some real problems with hate
speech legislation and the reason I have
problems with it is that it's not
obvious when speech is motivated by
hate.
Angry speech can feel like it's
motivated by hate,
but angry speech is the only kind of
speech in some sense that is indicative
of real disagreement.
I mean,
I'm not saying that all disagreement
should be angry.
I'm just saying that if there is real
disagreement,
the it's our anger is often the evidence
for the exam existence of real
disagreement and if there's real
disagreement,
angry people have to talk it out because
if they don't then well then a bunch of
terrible things happened.
First of all,
you start losing track of who the angry
people are.
Second,
they don't get to say what's on their
mind and even listened to themselves.
They don't get to have other people tell
them that they're wrong.
They don't get to modify their
viewpoints because talking is thinking,
you know,
and if you start people from talking,
then you stop them from thinking and
that's a really bad thing.
And then if you,
if you,
if you interpret hate speech too broadly
than you drive the so called haters
underground and then you don't know what
they're up to and when people go under
ground that isn't good.
That that's really not good.
You get the rise of all sorts of
underground political movements when
people aren't able to express what they
think,
even though it's unpleasant.
So if you want to know where the haters
are,
then you have to let them talk.
You know when we even tell two year olds
who are angry,
you say,
well use your words and the reason we
tell two year olds that is because the
alternative to using your words is using
your fists.
And so if we don't let angry people
talk,
then the only,
they only have two,
two alternatives.
Well apart from changing their mind and
they're not going to change their mind
just if you just shut someone up,
that doesn't change their mind because
partly the way you change your mind is
by talking and thinking and
communicating with other people.
And if you shut that avenue or for
people,
then they can change their minds.
Well then they either they pull it in
and get resentful,
you know,
that's one option.
They don't take any action or they get
aggressive and violent or they start
agitating for violence.
So you know,
I can't help but think that,
well,
there's a famous psychoanalyst,
Dick Psychoanalytic Dictum,
if you don't understand the motivation
for something,
look at the outcome and in further
motivation,
well if the outcome of shutting people
up is that they get violent,
then it's hard for me to suppress the
suspicion that it was the incitement of
violence that was at least part of the
initial motivation for,
for producing the restriction.
Now I think there's a lot more to it
than that.
You know,
I think a lot of it is a lot of this
desire for people not to ever say
anything upsetting is actually a
consequence of trait.
Agreeableness,
which is a big five psychological trait
and really agreeable people are
egalitarianism by nature,
but they also don't like conflict and
but what that means is they don't like
short term conflict.
You know,
they don't like anybody to be upset.
And the problem is sometimes you have to
be upset in the present to solve
problems in the medium and longterm.
You know,
you can't stop people from talking about
upsetting things because as I said,
that's just the same as topping them
from thinking and,
and if they can't think really
complicated things through well then
they don't solve problems and then the
problems manifest themselves in the real
world.
It's no joke.
So there's a recent case of Lionel
Shriver who's a WHO's A.
Well,
I won't talk about her.
You can look her up.
I'll try to stick to the point here.
So this is also part of bill
[inaudible].
This is modification of section two of
the Canadian Human Rights Act purpose.
The purpose of this act is to extend the
laws in Canada to give effect within the
purview of matters coming within the
legislative authority of parliament.
That's Canada's highest governing body,
the principle that all individuals
should have an opportunity equal with
other individuals to make for themselves
the lives that they are able and wished
to have and to have their needs
accommodated,
consistent with their duties and
obligations as members of society
without being hindered in or prevented
from doing so by discriminatory
practices based on race,
national,
or ethnic origin.
Color,
religion,
age,
sex,
sexual orientation,
and now hypothetically,
gender identity or expression,
marital status,
family status,
disability or conviction for an offense
for which at pardon has been granted or
in respect of which are record
suspension has been ordered.
Okay,
so well,
what's problematic about this?
Well,
I've outlined some of it in yellow.
I don't really like the idea of wished
to have the lives that they're able and
wish to have and then to have their
needs accommodated.
Well,
it's messy,
it's messy terminology.
It's not easy to delineate needs.
There's an infinite number of them.
It's very,
very difficult to determine whose needs
should take priority.
In fact,
that's why we have a free market
society.
We have a free market society so that
people's needs can be voted on in some
sense by the purchasing power of three
individuals so that nobody,
no central committee,
no governing body has to decide whose
needs should be accommodated.
It's an infinitely complex problem and
it can't be solved by fit.
It's not possible and this was happened
in places like this.
This,
this was attempted in places like the
Soviet Union were need decisions.
We're constantly made by centralized
committees and the consequences was
absolutely catastrophic.
Not only was it economically suicidal,
it was also murderous,
so the whole idea of having needs
accommodated is a very,
very.
It's a very,
very slippery idea and it sounds good,
but it's very,
very dangerous.
It's dangerous because the question who
decides who's needs are paramount is the
crucial question and how's that it's
answered is the crucial issue and that
can go seriously wrong.
And then,
well,
the inclusion of gender identity or
expression.
Well,
we'll,
we'll discuss that momentarily
and there's also modification of section
three for all purposes of this act.
The prohibited grounds of discrimination
or race,
national ethnic origin,
color,
religion,
age,
sex,
sexual orientation,
and then again,
newly gender identity or expression,
marital status,
family status.
So this is the criminal code
modification modification of subsection
three,
18,
four where they define an identifiable
group.
And this is for the purpose of
determining who fundamentally is
uttering hate speech or discriminatory
speech.
And this includes all the candidates we
already described,
color,
race,
religion,
national ethnic origin,
et Cetera,
and includes gender identity or
expression.
Um,
and so,
well we'll,
we'll continue to talk about that.
And then
there's modifications of sub paragraph
seven,
18 to a,
again with regards to hate crime,
evidence that the old fence was
motivated by bias,
prejudice,
or hate based on race,
national,
ethnic origin,
language,
color,
religion,
etc. Including gender identity or
expression or any other simpler similar
factor.
The old fence was motIvated.
Bye.
Okay.
So this sort of legislation has already
come into play and provinces in Canada,
alberta,
british columbia,
newfoundland and labrador,
nova scotia,
prince edward island and,
and ontario.
And I'm going to concentrate on ontario
because I think a lot of this is
emanating from a small coterie of people
behind the ontario human rights
commission,
which is a particularly pathological
organization in my estimation.
And perhaps the biggest enemy of freedom
currently extent in Canada.
And I don't say that lightly.
So the reason I think the ontario human
rights commission is,
is an emblematic institution in this
regard is partly because I think that
the social justice warrior type
activists are overrepresented in the
current
provincial government,
federal or the current liberal
provincial government.
And I can't help but shake this,
I can't help but manifest the suspicion
that that's partly because our current
premier is lesbian in her sexual
preference and that in itself doesn't
bother me one way or another.
I don't think it's relevant to the
political discussion except in so far as
the lbgt community has become
extraordinarily good at organizing
themselves and has a fairly pronounced
and very,
very sophisticated radical fringe and
I can't help but see the hand of that in
what I'm going to read to you and you
could make up your own mind and see if
you think the same thing.
So the wording on the ontario human
rights commission with regards to
legislation like bill [inaudible] is the
same.
It's identical to that on the canadian
department of justice.
I,
I've given you the links here.
And so that's another indication to me
that there's tremendous cross talk
between these institutions.
One at the provincial level that's the
ontario one at and one at the federal
level because the wording is identical.
So That's the argument for overlap.
And the other thing too,
with regards to the lbgt angle on this
is that the wording is identical in many
regards to that that's common generally
used by lbgt activists.
And so that's why I'm putting the
different organizations together.
And as I said before,
I'm not saying this is right,
it's what I've been able to sort out.
It's,
it's what I've been able to puzzle out
and I'm putting it forward as an element
of discussion.
Okay.
So here's some of the definitions that
they use and these are now explicit
categories and implicit presumptions of
our most fundamental legal structure.
So now these have become something.
These definitions have become something
more than fact.
They become facts that you questioned at
your legal peril.
So here's the first one,
gender identity.
This is directly from the ontario human
resource human rights commission
weBsite.
Gender identity is each person's
internal and individual experience of
gender.
It is their sense Of being a woman,
a man,
both neither or anywhere along the
gender spectrum.
Oh,
I'd also like to point out that that's
relatively.
ThiS is a petty thing to say I suppose,
but one of the things that struck me
about the ontario human rights
commission website is that it's very
poor,
very poorly written,
and this particular sentence is very
poorly written and
policy that's on its way to be
transformed into legislation should not
be poorly written because it means it's
been poorly thought through and poorly
specified and it means that the people
who are doing it,
art,
being careful and that makes me nervous
and so then there's things in here that
I don't believe to be true.
Gender identity is each person's sense
of being a woman,
a man,
both neither or anywhere along the
gender spectrum.
I don't know what neither means because
I don't know what the options are.
If you're not a man or a woman,
it's not obvious to me how you can be
both because those are by definition
binary categories.
There's an idea that there's a gender
spectrum,
but I don't think that that's a valid
id.
I don't think there's any evidence for
it.
Biological sexuality is ancient.
It's hundreds of millions of years
old and it's binary because there's two
forms of of,
of,
of biological sex.
Now,
of course this is predicated on the idea
that your gender is somehow independent
from your,
from your biological sex,
but that's a proposition,
not a fact,
and even if it's true,
it's even if it.
Even if it in some manner was determined
to be true,
it is certainly not determined to be
true to that degree now and certainly
not to the degree that it should be
instantiated in law at most.
It's an opinion and I think it's an ill
informed opinion.
I think it's a politiCally motivated to
neil informed opinion and now it's
sculpt the force of law and then there's
another modification which is gender
expression,
which is something different thAn gender
identity,
so I guess there's biological sex and
then on top of that there's gender
identity which is separate.
They're not even correlated that they
don't bear any relationship to one
another.
I guess one is choice or it isn't
exactly clear.
I mean,
here's one of the things I find very
confusing.
It seems to me that the leftist
activists have made the claim that with
regards to transsexual individuals,
for example,
that you can Be a man in a woman's body
and that that's a biological reality or
that you can be a woman in a man's body
and that's a biologiCal reality,
so as long as you're
gender identity is opposite to that of
your biological,
cardinal,
biological sexual attributes,
then that's biologically determined.
but if your gender identity is in sync
with your biological attributes,
theN that's a free floating cultural
construct.
Unless I've got my logic wrong somehow
and I cannot see how both of those
things can possibly be true,
but I don't think that coherence is one
of the hallmarks of radical politically
correct.
Think and you can tell that because
politically correct people like the
people who have produced this
Legislation and these policies are
capable of saying things like it.
Is there sense meaning each person's by
the way it?
Is there a sense of being.
Maybe
maybe an individual can decide to be a
plurality as well,
aNd that's why there is being used as
the pronoun in this particular sentence.
Although I think the real reason is is
that the person who wrote this can't
write it,
is there a sense of being a woman,
a man,
both neither or anywhere along the
gender spectrum?
From my perspective,
that Sentence is entirely nonsensical
and now it's law and then okay,
so we've got biological sex,
gender identity,
and then on toP of that we've got gender
expression,
which I guess is how you Express your
gender identity,
which is separate from your biological,
sexual orientation.
It's the way people publicly present
their gender.
It is the presentation of gender through
such aspects as dress,
hair,
makeup,
body language and voice.
Okay,
well those are canonical categories now
and it isn't clear to me because of the
legislation.
It is possible.
I believe it's possible that my
commentary on these definitions is now
illegal and that it's also now
potentially classifiable as hate speech
and I would say if that's the case then
like,
well it's the sort of thing I'm going to
question and if sOmeone should be put in
jail for questioning that and that I
questioning that,
then I guess I should be put in jail
because I'm going to continue to
question it.
I think it's nonsensicAl.
I think the formulation is absurd.
I think it has no scientific standing.
I think it's ideologically motivated.
I think it's divisive.
I think it's dangerous.
it causes chaos.
It confuses people.
There's no upside to it and for any,
for every one person that this potential
transformation of legislation is going
to free from oppression.
It's going to definitely confused 100
more
and I say that as I say that as a
clinician with some experience in this
matter,
more definitions.
The code does not define the grounds of
gender identity,
gender expression or sex instead.
the understanding of these and Other
related terms and the implications for
the code.
That's the ontario human rights code and
ontario human rights commission policies
is evolving from tribunals and court
decisions.
Social science research as well as self
identity and common everyday use more
defInitions.
Sex is the anatomical classification of
people as male,
female,
or intersex,
usually assigned at birth.
I should also point out that the closet,
a class of intersex is so rare to be
virtually nonexistent and it isn't
reasonable to make standard policy on
the basis of extreme exceptions,
and the reason for that is that there
are myriads,
millions of extreme exceptions,
and it's not possible to constitute a
collective society on the basis of
legislation that's designed for for
exceptions.
It can't be done by definition.
The laws to the law is fundamentally
there to produce a collective agreement.
Okay,
back definitions.
Once again,
gender identity is each person's
internal and individual experience of
gender.
We've already said that a person's
gender identity may be the same or the
same as or different from their birth
assigned sex.
Well,
that's the theory.
Gender expression is how a person
publicly expresses a or presents their
well.
We've covered that.
There's another addition here.
A person's chosen name and pronoun are
also common ways of expressing gender.
others perceive a person's gender
through those attributes.
Well,
this is also ontario human rights
commission policy.
Okay,
so this is the scenario I've been
running through my head.
I can envision a student or a colleague
insisting that I call call them using
gender neutral prOnouns.
She,
zed,
h e or z,
h d for you,
americans,
g or azure?
I think it is.
I'm not doing that.
I think it's manipulative.
I and I don't,
I don't.
Um,
I don't recognize anotHer person's right
to determine what pronouns I use to
address them.
I won't do it
now.
again,
I think that because of these new laws
and that,
that,
that my decision might be illegal and
maybe it's even a decision of hate,
but I'm not doing it.
I think that those gendeR neutral
pronouns are politically motivated.
I think they're connected to an entire
underground apparatus of political
motivations,
radical left political motivations.
And I think uttering those words makes
me a tool of those motivations.
And I'm going to try to be a tool of my
own motivations as Clearly as I can
articulate them and not the mouthpiece
of some murderous ideology.
A person's gender identity definitions
continued.
A person's gender identity is
fundamentally different from a not
related to their sexual orientation.
Well,
that's rubbish fundamentally because if
you ran a correlation analysis between
gender identity and sexual orientation,
the correlation is going to be something
like point nine five,
which indicates an almost perfect
correlation for the vast majority of
people.
Gender identity and sexual orientation
are the same thing,
and so it is not fundamentally different
from and not related to their sexual
orientation.
That's just a misstatement of fact
perhaps for a minority of people.
Sometimes there are dissociable,
but that that doesn't mean that a gender
identity is fundamentally different from
a not related to sexual orientation.
It's a complete misstatement of fact.
If there's a correlation of if there's a
correlation of any magnitude between two
things,
then one is related to another and when
the correlation is just about perfect,
well then they are fundamentally
related.
So.
So that's another policy that's based
actually on a lie,
a misstatement and untruth.
All right,
so trans or transgender as an umbrella
term,
referring to people with diverse gender
identities and expressions that differ
from stereotypical gender norms.
It includes but is not limited to people
who identify as transgender trans woman,
trans man,
transexual crossdressers or gender,
gender variant or gender queer.
Now,
here's what I think about these terms.
You see the people who use these terms
want everyone to believe that there are
for all the good things that they say
they're for,
but I don't believe any of that.
I don't think that there are for good
things at all.
I think that they use the pretense that
there for good things,
you know,
that they stand for good things to
continue their nefarious activity and
one of the most nefarious elements of
their activity is the use of these
ideological clubs.
You know,
when the club basically is,
here's the club,
I mean the kind of club that you hit
people with.
If there's a difference in outcome,
then it's a consequence of consequence
of racism and bias.
And then if I point out the difference,
then I'm a good person.
So my little routine for wandering
through the world,
making sure that I'm a good person,
unlike those other people who aren't
good people,
that that need to be punished and
perhaps jailed.
I look for inequalities and wherever I
find them,
I attribute them to racism and so that
means I can spend my whole life doing
nothing but being on the side of good by
ferreting out all the evil that resides
in other people and not in me.
I don't trust people like that.
I think the continual generation of
these terms is a consequence of the
desire to make that game continue for as
long as possible,
regardless of the consequences so that
the people who hold those opinions can
always be morally correct and have a
whole set of enemies to go after.
And that's why the terms keep
multiplying.
Because every time society moves to
become more tolerant,
more liberal,
well then that interferes with the game.
Because the game is while we have to
find racist and horrible people.
And so the solution to that is,
well,
let's just continue to generate
categories more and more categories to
demonstrate how unequal people are.
Well,
because the categories are infinitely
divisible and we'll get to that later.
It's a game that never runs out and if
you're a professional,
if you're someone whose profession is to
be politically correct or to be a social
justice warrior,
and that might be an academic,
especially a marxist one,
and in all sorts of sub disciplines will
also get to that later,
like sociology and social work and many
of the social sciences apart from those
two and educational psychology.
That's another major offender in social
psychology and other major offender.
Then you're,
you're publicly subsidized for your damn
viewpoints and if you can continue to
make the case that the world is full of
racists,
racists and people possessed by ethnic
hatred,
you know,
I'm persecuting the poor and minorities.
That your shtick lasts forever and you
can fully justify your,
your subsidized position as well as
being on the side of right and morality
and making the world better place.
WhAt a good deal for everyone who's
politically correct
definition of discrimination and
harassment.
Now,
these are truly terrifying
discrimination happens when a person
experiences negative treatment or impact
intentional or not because of their
gender identity or gender expression.
Okay?
And that could be age,
sex,
race,
etc. Okay,
think about that sentence.
Discrimination happens when a person
experiences negative treatment or
impact.
Okay?
So let's say negative impact.
Well,
so what that means is that if I say
something that makes you feel negative
emotion or maybe even interferes with
your happiness because those are
actually separate things,
then you've experienced negative impact.
Okay?
Now,
okay,
that's bad enough because it means that
you get to decide when what I've said is
not appropriate,
but the worst part of it,
and that's not so good because you could
misunderstand me or maybe what I'm
saying is right and you just don't like
it or you know,
there's a whole variety of reasons you
might get upset about what I say.
So the fact that you get upset about
something that's negative impact,
but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
something bad is how it might even mean
that something's good,
good has happened.
I don't think I've ever learned anything
in my entire life that wasn't preceded
by some kind of negative impact.
We always learn things the hard way,
but the worst part of it is the next
phrase,
discrimination happens when a person
experiences negative treatment or
impact,
intentional or not.
Okay?
So here,
think about this.
When,
when,
when you have little children and maybe
one one runs into the other knox,
knox,
even your child down,
you set your child up and the first
thing you say is,
well,
barbie didn't mean it.
And the reason you say that is beCause
we've learned and this is painful.
This is.
This is A painful thing that human
beings have learned.
It's at the base of our modern legal
systems that intent matters.
It isn't consequences that you judge its
intent.
If I accidentally run into you,
that's way different than if I run into
you on purpose.
You know,
if I,
if,
if I kill you accidentally,
that's manslaughter at at its worst,
if I kill you with intent,
that's,
that's the worst form of homicide.
We judge people on intent,
northern consequences,
and so this policy is designed to
reverse that.
It'S now possible that you can didn't
discriminate against someone and violate
the law and and I think maybe even be
persecuted for hate crimes because this
is written in such a messy manner by
doing somethIng accidental or
intentional or not
well,
who's going to judge that?
Well,
you can imagine who's going to judge
that.
The kind of people who would dare to
judge that
harassment.
Harassment is a fOrm of discrimination.
It can include sexually explicit or
other inappropriate comments,
not defined questions,
jokes,
name,
calling,
images,
email and social media.
It doesn't say wHat email and social
media content,
just email and social media,
which is anotheR indication of the
appalling level of literacy behind
these,
behind these statements,
transphobiC,
homophobic,
or other bullying,
sexual advances touching another
unwelcome and ongoing behavior that
insults demeans,
harms are threatened.
Some person in some way.
Alright,
so the first thing you might note is
that this has been written to cover the
broadest possible range of
possibilities.
That's the exact opposite of what good
legislation does,
so if you combine these discrimination
and harassment that the the policies
basically allow for people to like if I,
if I unintentionally negatively impact
you with a joke,
then I'm harassing you and that's well
on its way to being well to violation of
the ontario human rights code.
it's an offense according to the ontario
human rights commission and it's on the
way to being a hate crime as far as I
can tell with the modifications of
federal legislation.
So and then to cap it all off,
they throw this in at the end of the
sentence,
other unwelcome and ongoing behavior
that insults demeans,
harms or threatens a person in some way.
Okay,
so that's all pretty scary,
but then there's more of course.
And so this is the ontario human rights
commission developing policies on
organizational liability.
So listen to this.
Organizations are liable for any
discrimination and harassment that
happens.
They are also liable for not
accommodating and a trans person needs,
unless it would cause undue hardship.
Well,
the whole issue of undue hardship is a
tricky one because I'm not exactly sure
who adjudicates that in.
You know,
we'll get to that later.
They must deal with complaints,
take steps to prevent problems and
provide a safe welcoming environment for
trans people.
Okay.
And,
and you know,
old people and,
and ethnic,
ethnically diverse people and you know,
differently gendered people and all of
that.
So fine organizations are liable for any
discrimination and harassment that
happens.
Okay,
well that puts a hell of an onus on the
organization because it isn't exactly
clear to me how organizations are going
to monitor all of their people all of
the time in the organizations.
What if they're using social media
outside the organization?
So organizations are now liable for all
of this.
So how are you going to police all that?
Okay,
next
more on liability
from the ontario human rights code under
section 46 point three of the code,
a corporation trade union or
occupational association,
unincorporated association or employees
organization.
Now listen to this will be held
responsible for discrimination including
acts or omissions committed by employees
or agents in the course of their
employment.
This is known as vicarious liability.
Okay.
Responsible parties violate the code.
Now this is where it gets.
This is where it gets horrible,
I think where they directly or
indirectly,
intentionally or unintentionally
infringed the code or rather the
otherwise authorized,
condoned or adopt behavior that is
contrary to the code.
It is unacceptable to choose to remain
unaware,
ignore or fail to address potential or
actual human rights violations.
Whether or not a complaint is made,
god you couldn't possibly design a
broader definition of liability
potential or actual human rights
violations.
Whether or not a complaint is made,
okay,
so does that.
That means that you have vicarious
liability.
If you fail to address a potential human
rights violation,
whether or not a complaint is made.
The only thing I can say about
legislation that's written in this
manner is that it seems to me to be
consciously designed to get as many
people in trouble as possible.
That's it.
It,
it.
It's designed to get as many people as
possible in trouble at the same time,
so that brings us to the end of part one
of this talk on political correctness in
it described the increasing fear that's
spread by politically correct activism
throughout large organizations including
academic institutions like the
university of toronto.
I also discussed the increasing all
pervasiveness of this viewpoint because
it's not something that's localized
anymore to academic institutions.
It's spread beyond them and his is
characteristic of the preoccupations of,
of a certain kind of administrator at a
very large multitude of large
organizations.
And I described in detail the canadian
bill [inaudible],
which is an attempt to modify the
canadian human rights code and the
criminal code a to make a whole variety
of speech acts and the holding of
certain opinions or the articulate
lading of them,
um,
criminal and maybe even criminal under
the provisions of the hate of hate crime
legislation.
In part two,
I'm going to give you a more detailed
analysis of the university of toronto's
attempts to transform its hr department
into a politically correct organization.
I'm using the,
the goals of the university of toronto
as a cautionary tale about how such
political maneuvers operate at a local
level.
Again,
on the principle that a good story about
something local is a good story about
something with general significance.
In part three,
I'm going to talk about what individuals
can do about these sorts of things,
what you as a citizen,
how you as a citizen might arm yourself
intellectually so that you can
articulate a stance against this kind of
movement if you feel that that's in your
best interests.
Thanks for listening.
If you want to support endeavors such as
these,
such as these,
please visit my patriot on site which
allows you to do so.
It's a monthly subscription site that
helps me develop these videos and
continue my work on them.
Um,
and who knows if things keep up the way
they are.
Maybe it'll be my only source of income.
Um,
after it becomes impossible for me to
work at a university and say what I want
to say.
If you want to provide such support,
just google patrion,
Jordan Peterson.
Thanks a lot,
and we'll talk to you very soon.